Essential information from Fine Living.
One of the things you could do for Grandparents Day is to go through old photo albums.
While doing this, the family stories come up and the oral histories that are shared,...
...which is really important, especially for a child, to get that feeling...
...of their family history and their place in the family.
Younger children, they just love the whole idea of family trees.
They can actually draw a tree and place different members of the family on the family tree.
And they can also have dinner for their grandparents.
They can cook, they love to do this.
Little children love to make dinners for their grandparents.
So on Grandparents Day, it would be wonderful to teach one of the old songs from way back when.
And the important thing is to remember the act of doing it alongside of the grandparent.
Think it's just spending the time interacting, the grandparent and the grandchild,...
...building that relationship and nurturing each other.
The interaction is so beneficial to both.